fut de lire un tas d'articles sur ça.
En janvier 2018,
j'ai lu un article contenant le témoignage de certaines victimes supposées.
Ce qui m'a particulièrement frappée dans cet article
fut l'ampleur de leur peur.
Elles étaient vraiment effrayées.
Elles avaient posé des caches sur l'appareil photo de leur téléphone
et de leur ordinateur.
Elles craignaient qu'il ne soit un hacker
et viennent espionner leurs données
afin de détruire leur vie.
C'est pour cela qu'elles s'étaient tues si longtemps.
J'étais furieuse.
Je voulais que plus personne ne ressente jamais cela.
J'ai donc agi comme je le fais souvent quand je suis en colère :
j'ai tweeté.
(Rires)
J'ai tweeté ceci :
Si vous êtes une femme victime d'un abus sexuel par un hacker,
et que ce hacker vous a menacée d'espionner vos machines,
contactez-moi
et je veillerai à vérifier votre machine de fond en comble.
Et je suis allée déjeuner.
(Rires)
10 000 tweets plus tard,
j'ai compris que j'avais lancé un nouveau projet.
Chaque matin, au réveil, ma messagerie était saturée
d'histoires d'hommes et de femmes
qui me racontaient la pire chose qui leur soit arrivée.
J'ai été contactée par des femmes espionnées par des hommes,
par des hommes espionnés par des hommes,
par des femmes espionnées par des femmes,
mais la grande majorité des personnes
étaient des femmes qui avaient été abusées sexuellement par des hommes
et qui les espionnaient.
Un cas particulièrement intéressant
concerne un homme qui m'a contactée
car son compagnon avait dénoncé son homosexualité
à sa famille coréenne extrêmement conservatrice.
Il n'y a donc pas que le seul scénario d'hommes qui espionnent des femmes.
Je souhaite vous faire part de ce que j'ai appris de cette expérience.
J'ai appris que les données fuitent.
Comme de l'eau.
Dans des endroits indésirables.
Les humains fuitent.
Vos amis lâchent des informations sur vous.
Votre famille lâche des informations sur vous.
Vous allez à une réception,
quelqu'un vous tague présent à cette fête.
C'est un des moyens utilisés par les agresseurs
pour obtenir des informations
que vous ne souhaitez pas qu'ils sachent.
Il n'est pas rare que des agresseurs approchent des amis ou la famille
en demandant des infos sur leur victime
sous prétexte qu'ils sont inquiets pour leur « santé mentale ».
Une forme de fuite que j'ai rencontrée
est appelée : « compte compromis »
Vous avez un compte Gmail,
un compte Twitter,
un compte Instagram,
un compte iCloud,
un identifiant Apple,
un compte Netflix, Tiktok --
j'ai dû chercher ce qu'était Tiktok.
S'il y a un login,
il était toujours compromis
parce que votre agresseur n'est pas toujours votre agresseur.
C'est très habituel pour des couples de partager leurs mots de passe.
De plus, dans une relation intime,
on se connaît en profondeur
et on peut deviner les questions de sécurité.
On peut lire par-dessus l'épaule
et déchiffrer le code de déverrouillage du téléphone.
On a un accès physique au téléphone
ou à l'ordinateur.
Cela crée autant d'occasions
pour bidouiller les comptes des autres,
ce qui est très dangereux.
La bonne nouvelle est que nous avons des conseils
pour verrouiller les comptes.
C'est un conseil qui existe déjà et qui recommande ceci :
utilisez des mots de passe complexes uniques pour chacun de vos comptes.
Utilisez des mots de passe plus robustes et uniques
comme réponse aux questions de sécurité
afin d'empêcher quiconque connaissant le nom du chien de votre enfance
de changer votre mot de passe.
Enfin, réglez le système d'authentification à double facteur
à son niveau le plus haut - si vous le trouvez pratique.
Ainsi, même si un agresseur parvient à mettre la main sur vos mots de passe,
il n'aura pas le second facteur
et ne pourra donc pas entrer dans votre compte.
Vous devez aussi
vérifier les paramètres de sécurité et protection de la vie privée
de tous vos comptes.
La plupart des comptes ont ce paramètre
qui vous indique quelles machines sont actives sur le compte
et depuis où.
Par exemple, je suis ici,
sur mon compte Facebook depuis La Quinta,
où nous avons cette conférence,
et si, par exemple,
je regarde mes logins Facebook,
et je vois que quelqu'un a accédé à mon compte depuis Dubai,
je trouverais cela suspect
car je n'ai pas visité Dubaï récemment.
Mais parfois, il peut s'agir d'un RAT [Remote Access Tool],
c'est-à-dire un outil d'administration à distance.
C'est le terme que nous utilisons pour parler de logiciel espion.
Une des raisons qui rendent tentant l'accès à vos machines
pour les gouvernements
est la même que celle qui rend tentant l'accès à vos machines
par des partenaires malintentionnés ou des anciens partenaires.
Nous portons sur nous des traceurs toute la journée.
Nous portons des machines qui contiennent tous nos mots de passe
pour tous nos moyens de communication
y compris les communications chiffrées de bout en bout.
Tous nos courriels, tous nos contacts,
tous nos selfies sont réunis dans un seul endroit,
et souvent avec nos informations financières.
Dès lors, avoir un accès total à un téléphone,
c'est quasiment comme accéder à l'esprit de son propriétaire.
Les logiciels espions mettent cet accès à disposition.
Comment cela fonctionne-t-il ?
Les logiciels espions
sont des programmes conçus par des sociétés,
achetés par des agresseurs.
Ceux-ci installent le programme sur la machine qu'ils veulent espionner
souvent car ils ont un accès physique
ou en poussant leur cible à l'installer à leur insu
en disant, par exemple :
« C'est un programme très important à installer sur votre machine. »
Ensuite, ils paient la société qui leur a vendu le programme d'espionnage
pour accéder à un portail
qui leur donne accès à toutes les informations de la machine.
Cela coûte environ 40 dollars par mois.
Ce genre d'espionnage est vraiment bon marché.
Les sociétés savent-elles
que leurs logiciels
sont utilisés pour abuser des personnes ?
Absolument.
La lecture du matériel de promotion de Cocospy,
un de ces produits espions,
est explicite dès la première page de leur site :
« Cocospy vous permet d'épier votre épouse facilement. »
« Ne vous inquiétez plus de ses déplacements,
à qui elle parle ou des sites internet qu'elle visite. »
Ça fait froid dans le dos.
HelloSpy, un autre de ces produits,
a une page marketing avec un seul message
sur la prépondérance de l'infidélité
et sur l'importance cruciale de prendre son conjoint sur le fait,
avec une photo d'un homme
qui vient de prendre sa partenaire la main dans le sac
et l'a frappée.
Elle a un œil au beurre noir et du sang sur le visage.
Je pense que c'est assez explicite
quel est le parti pris de HelloSpy dans ce cas précis.
Et qui sont les clients qu'ils souhaitent atteindre.
Si vous avez un logiciel espion dans votre ordinateur ou votre téléphone,
c'est difficile de savoir si c'est le cas ou pas.
Une des raisons pour cela
est que les vendeurs d'antivirus
ne reconnaissent pas ces logiciels comme étant malveillants.
Ils ne les considèrent pas comme des chevaux de Troie
ou toutes les autres choses dont on espère normalement
une alerte de leur part.
Voici des résultats de cette année de VirusTotal.
Pour un des échantillons que j'ai examinés,
j'avais un résultat de 7 sur 60
des plateformes qui détectaient le logiciel espion que je testais.
Avec celui-ci, j'ai obtenu 10 détections,
10 sur 61.
Ce sont des résultats vraiment mauvais.
J'ai réussi à convaincre quelques vendeurs d'antivirus
de classer les logiciels espions comme malveillants.
Tout ce que vous avez à faire,
si vous craignez d'avoir ces logiciels sur votre ordinateur,
est de télécharger le programme,
scanner et regarder le résultat :
« Il y a un logiciel potentiellement non voulu dans votre machine. »
Il vous offre la possibilité de l'enlever
mais cela ne se fait pas automatiquement.
Une des raisons pour cela
est la dynamique des agressions.
Souvent, les victimes d'un abus ne sont pas convaincues
de vouloir, ou pas, alerter leur agresseur
en leur supprimant l'accès.
Elles sont parfois inquiètes que leur partenaire devienne violent,
ou encore plus violent
que ce qu'il était déjà.
Kaspersky est une des premières sociétés
à s'être engagées à prendre cette menace au sérieux.
En novembre 2019,
ils ont publié un rapport disant
que depuis qu'ils suivent les logiciels espions chez leurs utilisateurs,
ils ont constaté une augmentation de 35%.
De même, Lookout a publié un engagement
à prendre cette menace plus au sérieux.
Malwarebytes, enfin, a publié un engagement semblable
en affirmant avoir détecté 2 500 programmes
la première fois qu'ils ont fait une recherche
et qui peuvent être classifiés comme logiciel espion.
En novembre, j'ai contribué au lancement d'une coalition
appelée coalition contre les logiciels espions,
formée par des universitaires,
des gens qui sont sur le terrain,
et des praticiens qui aident les victimes de violences domestiques à en échapper,
et des vendeurs d'antivirus.
Notre objectif est de faire connaître au public l'existence de ces programmes
et de convaincre les vendeurs d'antivirus
de changer leurs normes
de gestion de ces logiciels si effrayants
avec l'espoir que si je reviens dans un an
sur cette scène pour vous parler de ça,
je pourrais vous dire que le problème est résolu,
que vous n'avez plus qu'à télécharger n'importe quel antivirus
et qu'il fera une détection de routine des logiciels espions.
C'est mon espoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)